[Music]
your world is not as it seems everything
you know to be true is a lie hidden
behind the facade of our everyday lives
is a secret and Powerful organization
with a dangerous agenda to manipulate
the minds of the masses and Usher in a
new world order they call this program
project bluebeam if the program is
successful we won't see it coming
borders between nations will be
dissolved all religions will be
dismantled and Technology will be turned
against us the architects of project
bluebeam will distract us with false
flag operations like Global pandemics
strange weather events and news reports
of UFOs being shot down all over the
world what's frightening is the general
population will go along with Project
Blue beam willingly without resistance
even more frightening it's already begun
foreign
was a mysterious and controversial
figure born in Quebec in 1945 he was an
investigative journalist who became
weary of the direction in which society
was headed he believed that there was a
secret cabal of powerful Elites who were
controlling the World Behind the Scenes
in other words the Illuminati oh really
did he also believe what is wet disguise
blue and nfts are a scam of course you
believe in the Illuminati is this a
tinfoil hat in my head or am I just
happy to see you I don't think that's
how that saying goes how many of these
stupid shows have we done well a little
over a hundred but I don't think they're
stupid you know all this time you think
some of my knowledge
now Rubble off on you well now you're
being let me speak slowly so even a
human can understand the Illuminati uh
real
surgeman asked was determined to expose
these Elites even when his life was in
danger in 1994 he released his book
project bluebeam which outlines the plan
to create a one world government and a
new world order project bluebeam was
conceived during the Cold War the United
States and the Soviet Union were
spending vast amounts of money and
resources on technology to gain the
upper hand no idea was off the table now
publicly the superpowers were building
tanks and planes and nuclear weapons but
privately they were experimenting with
mind control and psychic Warfare
obviously Research into mind control
wasn't new the most well-known research
is probably the cia's MK Ultra program
which began in 1953 but Project Blue
beam is a dramatic step forward while
programs like MK Ultra use drugs for
mind control project bluebeam uses
technology so instead of being run by
the CIA bluebeam is controlled by NASA
under the direction of the United
Nations project bluebeam is a four-step
plan that uses a combination of advanced
techno technology and psychological
manipulation to create an illusion so
convincing that no one can distinguish
reality from the illusion
we must remember that the New Age
religion is the very foundation for the
new world government without which the
dictatorship is completely impossible
that is why the bluebeam project is so
important to them but has been so well
hidden until now replacing every
religion on Earth with a new single
religion would not be an easy task in
order to succeed project bluebeam would
have to create weather events and
man-made earthquakes it would need to
replace all the world's currencies with
a single electronic currency it would
need to use Holograms augmented reality
and artificial intelligence it would
need a way to plant fake news stories
and propaganda and distribute those to
the masses directly circumventing all
news media and elected officials when
Serge manast exposed project bluebeam
these Technologies just didn't exist yet
but now they do
foreign
was convinced that NASA and the United
Nations were behind project bluebeam a
Sinister four-step program to establish
a new world order this would be
implemented through advanced mind
control and top secret technology in the
first stage of the project we'll see a
breakdown of all archaeological
knowledge this is done by creating
artificial earthquakes these earthquakes
would be at strategically placed
locations around the globe at these
locations new discoveries will be made
that will show that religions have been
misunderstood and misinterpreted for
centuries this would allow science to
discredit all religious doctrines look
at the Dead Sea Scrolls for hundreds of
years the Bible was thought to be
complete then in 1947 a Shepherd finds
some clay jars in a cave suddenly there
are new religious texts like the book of
jubilees the wisdom of Solomon and the
Book of Tobit this discovery didn't
fundamentally change religion but it did
cause Scholars to think what else are we
missing project bluebeam capitalizes on
that kind of doubt it's designed to
cause a crisis of faith for every Jew
Christian Muslim and Buddhist people in
crisis will be more likely to accept the
New Age religion as for earthquakes
these can be artificially created by
mining or fracking in the right location
there's also research being done on
creating earthquakes with sound waves
this is called induced seismicity and
the frequency and severity of
earthquakes has been increasing over the
past 20 years phase two of project
bluebeam is what Manassas called the
space show 3D holographic images and
sounds will be projected from a network
of satellites these satellites will use
lasers to project images down to earth
these images will be designed to seduce
people into believing in a new God
Holograms and augmented reality is
getting better and better every year
this video surfaced out of China and it
looks like their city is floating in the
Clouds of course we can't verify if the
video is real or not but we have seen
things like this before the image scene
and language heard will be different in
different parts of the world according
to what religion is most dominant in the
area then all the different deities from
all the world's religions will merge
into one
then the projections of Jesus Muhammad
Buddha and Krishna will merge into one
and explanations of mysteries and
Revelations will be disclosed this one
God will in fact be the Antichrist who
will explain that the various scriptures
had been misunderstood and
misinterpreted and that the religions of
old are responsible for turning brother
against brother a nation against Nation
therefore old religions must be
abolished to make way for the new age
new world religion representing the one
God Antichrist they see before them
now earthquakes and religious artifacts
will be enough to convert some people to
this new religion giant deities
appearing and then converging into one
Antichrist will convert a lot more
people but these Technologies won't work
on everybody non-religious people will
be terrified sure but they won't
suddenly believe in God based on a
hologram no matter how real it looks to
get the entire planet to adopt a new
religion and a one world government
people need to come to this decision
themselves if seeing a hologram of the
message isn't enough project bluebeam
will broadcast the message directly into
our brains and that technology is
available everywhere in the world right
now
now we can see a new world coming into
view
a world in which there is the very real
Prospect of a new world order we have
before us the opportunity to forge for
ourselves and for future Generations a
new world order
the goal of project bluebeam is to get
the entire planet to adopt a single
religion and then a single government
and this will happen in four steps step
one is to use artificial earthquakes and
archaeological discoveries to discredit
existing religions step two is through
Holograms augmented reality and AI to
make people believe that a new God has
arrived to replace all existing Gods
step three is mind control using
microwaves so they put secret messages
in popcorn and Frozen Guinness no not
microwave ovens microwaves are small
radio waves oh these electromagnetic
waves are all around us all the time
they're in the air they move through our
homes through our bodies through
everything all cell phones use
microwaves the frequencies are typically
between 800 and 2200 megahertz 5G
operates between 28 and 39 gigahertz
don't have a cell phone doesn't matter
baby monitors garage door openers
Bluetooth devices the Wi-Fi in your home
all use radio waves RFID tags wireless
earbuds remote control toys MRI machines
and yes even microwave ovens we are
constantly swimming in electromagnetic
radiation there's no way to escape it
you'll have much protection from a tin
foil hit not nearly enough two team foil
hits Please can I
step three of Project Blue beam seizes
control of the full EM spectrum and uses
it to control our very thoughts
the third step in the bluebeam project
uses electronically augmented two-way
communication where elf vlf and LF waves
will reach each person from within his
or her own mind convincing each of them
that their own God is speaking to them
from the very depths of their own soul
such Rays from satellites are fed from
the memories of computers that have
stored massive data about every human on
earth and their languages the Rays will
then interlace with their natural
thinking to form what we call the fuse
artificial thought that kind of
Technology goes into the 1970s 1980s and
1990s research where the human brain has
been compared to a computer information
is set in processed integrated and then
a response is formulated and acted upon
we already have technology like
neurolink where the mind can control a
machine project bluebeam lets a machine
control the Mind step four is the most
Insidious of all it describes how
project bluebeam will create a fake
disaster or crisis that will bring the
world together but not through hope or
through peace the world will come
together for fear this event will be so
frightening that people will no longer
care about their religion or their
National or cultural identity they'll be
so scared that they won't resist the One
World Government they'll Beg For It
manasse gave a specific example of what
project bluebeam would use to terrify
the world and it may already be
happening project bluebeam would stage a
fake invasion of UFOs
[Music]
this morning questions after more
unidentified objects are discovered over
U.S and Canadian airspace for dramatic
new details about the unidentified
objects shot down by fighter jets they
didn't have propulsion they weren't
being maneuvered it was basically
they've been being driven uh by the by
the wind unidentified objects shot down
by U.S fighter jets over the weekend
three objects over three days can't work
out exactly how they fly and they won't
rule out the fact that they might even
be extraterrestrial for the third time
in as many days the U.S had spotted and
shot down an unidentified object what is
going on here with what seemed like a
deluge of potential incursions what are
these objects where are they coming from
what is their purpose
Serge benass said the fourth step in
project bluebeam would be what he called
a universal Supernatural manifestation
with electronic means in other words a
false flag attack one is to make mankind
believe that an alien invasion is about
to occur at every major city on earth in
order to provoke each major Nation to
use its nuclear weapons in order to
strike badak the United Nations Court
will require that all nations which
launched nuclear weapons disarm when the
invasion is shown to be false and how
will the United Nations know that the
invasion was false it will have
stationed of course
now it's hard not to notice what's been
happening with UFOs or uaps over the
last few years for my entire life UFOs
were considered a fringe idea then
whistleblowers like Bob Lazar started to
emerge who claimed to have worked on
UFOs at area 51. then we got reports
from Navy pilots who claimed to see UFOs
then we saw a video then the government
acknowledged that not only do UFOs exist
but they don't have any idea what they
are since then their reports and images
and video of objects in the skies all
over the world as I record this the
United States has shot down four
unidentified objects in the span of
About a Week according to project
bluebeam this quickening of events is
all intentional it started with movies
like 2001 A Space Odyssey and
Independence Day and television shows
like Star Trek these were to get the
public use to the idea that it was just
a matter of time before science fiction
became science fact a few decades later
military jets are firing missiles at
UFOs and the news is reporting on it it
would seem that the next logical step is
for the UFOs to start firing back now
obviously there's no military on Earth
that can defeat such advanced technology
so they'll deploy the most destructive
weapons they have nuclear weapons in the
aftermath The Architects of project
bluebeam will reveal that the alien
attack was staged then after watching
their cities burn the people of Earth
will be outraged and demand that all
countries disarm all according to plan
again when project bluebeam is
implemented the world's population won't
resist the New World Order they'll
demand it for their own protection and
by the time they realize what they've
done it'll be too late
[Music]
foreign
this is what needs to be done in order
to actuate this false flag operation
that will involve the Abduction of
citizens so as to Foster an illusion
that this Earth is facing an
extraterrestrial Invasion use of
experimental drugs holographic
projection capabilities directed Energy
Technologies I'll get into that in a
moment induced auditory input
experimental aircraft or that's just a
euphemism for man-made UFOs and special
effects costuming and stagecraft
in addition to staging a fake Alien
Invasion project bluebeam will Implement
other programs to terrify the world's
population into compliance one of these
is a plot to convince Christians that
the Rapture is happening and for those
who don't know the Rapture is pretty
strong by Blondie no and out comes a man
from us and you try to run but he's got
a gun and he shoots you dead and it eats
your head ninja in a man from as you go
out at night eating cause you eat cattle
eggs Lincoln stew Mercury's and Subarus
and you don't stop stop and you don't
stop stop okay okay sheesh what a grouch
the Rapture is a term used by some
Christians to describe an event that
happens at the end of the world where
Jesus returns to Earth to take all of
his followers to heaven now project
bluebeam will stage a divine
intervention from Jesus to help save
Humanity from the Alien Invasion also
during this time electronic waves will
be transmitted over every wire on Earth
and these waves will induce psychosis in
large number of people this will cause a
wave of violence so severe that the
population will be ready to re-establish
peace at any cost even at the expense of
personal freedom Serge benass said The
Architects will phase out cash and
National currencies replacing them with
a single electronic currency this sounds
a lot like Bitcoin a Bitcoin was created
by Satoshi Nakamoto but nobody knows who
that is it could be one person or a
group of people or it could be the
Illuminati right nobody knows project
bluebeam has four specific goals abolish
religion abolish pride in one's country
dissolve the family in favor of the
state and Destroy individual creativity
if you don't see these things happening
now you're not paying attention as you
would expect surgeman asked ruffled a
lot of feathers when he revealed project
bluebeam to the world he claimed he was
being watched and followed in fact in
September 1996 his two homeschooled
children were taken from him and made
Wards of the state so they could receive
a public education run by the government
yep he never saw them again on December
4th 1996 Serge menast was arrested for
spreading misinformation he was
questioned and spent the night in jail
the next day he was found dead in his
apartment even though he was in perfect
health the official report is he died of
a heart attack at the age of 51. and so
sergeman asked the man who refused to be
silenced was finally silenced after all
[Music]
the idea of project bluebeam suggests
that NASA is planning to create a fake
Alien Invasion using holographic
technology the theory suggests that the
purpose of this event is to frighten the
world's population to make it easier to
create a new world order under a One
World Government
but is it true well there's no way to
fully debunk a theory like this because
anything happening behind the scenes is
presumably still behind the scenes but
let me give you the complete picture so
you can make up your own mind according
to manast Step One is in his words the
setup of earthquakes at certain precise
locations of the planet were supposedly
new discoveries will suddenly explain
the wrong meaning of all major religions
basic doctrines and yes earthquakes can
be created but they can't be created
discreetly you need large teams of
people and huge equipment there's no way
to do this and go unnoticed so let's
discount that as for convincing people
to give up their faith good luck with
that trying to eliminate religion has
been tried over and over again
throughout history and it's never worked
ancient Rome tried to eliminate
Christianity by persecuting Christians
instead of destroying it it became the
largest religion on the planet the
Soviet Union tried to eliminate religion
which the government saw as an obstacle
to the Socialist Utopia socialist Utopia
isn't actually [__] communist China
tried the same thing in the 1960s and
70s these governments closed places of
worship and destroyed religious
artifacts they arrested and sometimes
executed religious leaders from all
faiths these governments believed that
religion was a relic of the past that
needed to be destroyed in order to
create a modern rational Society now if
you pay attention you can even see this
type of thinking creeping into modern
media past died
kill it if you have to
the past is dead
we either move forward or we die with it
but none of this worked people simply
worshiped in secret project bluebeam
wanted to break down the traditional
family and make all people loyal to the
state first this too can be seen in
modern media but there is no person no
government and no movie studio powerful
enough to overcome the strength of Faith
and family it fails every time now step
two is using Holograms to project the
image of a new God and convince people
to worship a new Antichrist the
technology to make that kind of hologram
convincing enough just doesn't exist now
for a few years there have been videos
floating around the internet showing
very realistic Holograms as a way to
support the existence of project
bluebeam none of these are real these
are nothing more than CGI and augmented
reality now AR allows users to see 3D
objects in the physical world but only
through a device like a smartphone or a
television so when you see videos like
this we see the animals in the shot
through the camera the people in the
shot don't see them but those aren't
Holograms a hologram is an object that
can be seen floating in space by an
observer without a camera but Holograms
need a substrate or a medium meaning the
light has to be projected into something
usually this is done using layered glass
or plastic and even good Holograms don't
look very good a fun 3D technique that
always fascinated to me has been around
for 200 years it's called Pepper's ghost
after John Henry pepper who popularized
it the effect is created using a sheet
of glass placed at an angle between the
viewer and the object the object is
projected onto the glass using a hidden
projector this effect has been used very
effectively to simulate live
performances of dead musicians Tupac
wrapped on stage with Snoop Dogg at
Coachella Michael Jackson performed at
the Billboard Music Awards Roy Orbison
Buddy Holly and Whitney Houston all went
on tour and played the sold out crowds
but view these projections at the wrong
angle or in a bright room the illusion
is broken you're not going to fool
billions of people using any of these
techniques but that's where step three
comes in mind control using advanced
technology project bluebeam will
convince us that what we're seeing is
real now it's terrifying to say but this
technology actually exists
[Music]
after World War II at the start of the
Cold War the Us and other countries
researched mind control Technologies for
military and intelligence purposes the
most notorious is the cia's MK Ultra
program which used drugs and hypnosis on
people many against their will that
program was eventually shut down amid
public outrage allegedly shut down right
now mind control technology has
continued to evolve transcranial
magnetic stimulation or TMS uses
magnetic fields to stimulate activity in
specific areas of the brain and TMS has
been used to treat mental health
conditions such as depression and
anxiety brain computer interfaces or
bcis allow people to control computers
using their thoughts you might be
familiar with Elon musk's company
neurolink neurolink uses bcis with the
goal of enhancing people's cognitive
abilities all you have to do is have a
microchip surgically implanted into your
brain oh yeah great idea what could
possibly go wrong
electroconvulsive stimulation or east TS
is a medical treatment that involves
sending electrical impulses into the
brain to induce a brief seizure this
kind of reboots the brain and is used to
treat chronic depression and other
mental illnesses the military uses ECS
on fighter pilots to increase their
performance you can even buy these
devices online or build them yourself
but I don't recommend that because
scientists don't really know how it
works yet they just know that it does so
in theory project bluebeam could use ECS
on the entire world's population to
control our Behavior but that would need
a tremendous amount of electricity and
wouldn't be very discreet finally step
four of project bluebeam is faking an
alien attack this actually wouldn't be
hard to do all you really need is a
story and a compliant media to tell it
well we have that we do news agencies no
longer challenge politicians that they
agree with now that's dangerous because
boss flag operations do happen in 1962
the United States Department of Defense
proposed operation Northwoods the plan
and called for the shooting down of the
U.S civilian aircraft attacks on U.S
bases and the staging of attacks on U.S
cities all to create the illusion that
America was being attacked by Cuba
President Kennedy rejected the idea but
if it went forward the U.S would have
secretly attacked its own citizens in
1964 the United States Destroyer USS
Maddox was attacked twice in the Gulf of
Tonkin off the coast of Vietnam the U.S
immediately escalated its involvement in
the Vietnam War but the second attack on
the Maddox it never happened the United
States would see 50 000 soldiers killed
and over 300 000 wounded in a losing War
based partially on lies told by the
United States government now all
governments have carried out false flag
operations throughout history faking a
UFO attack wouldn't be that difficult at
least not on a small scale let me ask
you those UFOs that were shot down by
the U.S has anyone seen the wreckage
maybe by the time you're watching this
there will be a logical explanation for
what happened and but as of now nobody
really knows and if the US government
knows it isn't talking as the surgeman
asked death he did die the very next day
after being detained by authorities now
that could be a coincidence but it's a
story we hear all too often with
whistleblowers now that's disturbing
because often the only thing standing
between a conspiracy theory and the
truth is one Brave whistleblower and
that's why even though I believe there
are many elements of project bluebeam
that are true the entire story probably
isn't surgeman asked often referred to
Star Trek as a way of getting people
ready to accept project bluebeam now
this is interesting because a few months
before he released his book a biography
on Gene rodberry was released the guy
who created Star Trek yep that guy and
in the book was the plot of an
unreleased Star Trek movie that
Roddenberry wrote the movie was called
the God thing the plot of the movie was
how an alien convinces everyone on Earth
that it's a god using technology in 1991
an episode of stars Trek the Next
Generation was released called Devil's
Due the plot was about an alien using
technology to convince a planet that
she's God so she can enslave the
population she uses mind control and
Holograms to do this oh so when did this
cat release his blue book about 18
months after the episode aired oh right
project bluebeam sounds like science
fiction because it was probably based on
science fiction but even if it wasn't I
don't think project bluebeam could work
on us not today when we're also
connected and information moves so
quickly around the world you couldn't
pull off a worldwide conspiracy like
this without an army of people
supporting it an army of Regular People
Like Us just think of the technical
expertise required the number of
computer Engineers Carpenters
electricians here's what I want you to
do go to Bilderberg or Davos or Bohemian
Grove and ask any of those super wealthy
Elites what the IP and TCP stands for
Internet Protocol ask them how far apart
you should space your studs when framing
wall 16 on Santa ask them what wires are
hot in Romex Electrical cable red and
black the elites may run the world but
they can't do anything not without us so
they're going to convince an army of
people to create an illusion to fool
billions into accepting a new world
order the elites are going to turn
entire armies of soldiers against their
neighbors against their children it
can't be done and the elites they know
it they know they can push us but only
so far they know they can control us but
not all of us not at once because like I
said no matter how much money you have
or how much power you'll never have more
power than family and faith and Faith
doesn't just mean religion I'm not a
religious person but I still have faith
I have faith in my friends and my
neighbors I have faith in you I have
faith that when tyranny arrives you'll
resist and I'll join you we'll resist
tyranny with words and if words aren't
enough we'll use violence just like our
grandfathers did when they stormed the
beach at Normandy and just like a
million Farmers did 250 years ago to
liberate their country from a tyrannical
King the elites know this and that's why
they fear us they have money and they
have power but we have something they
don't have
we have each other
thank you so much for hanging out with
us today my name is AJ that's Echo fish
this has been the Y files if you had fun
or learned anything do me a favor and
like subscribe comment and share yeah
stuff really helps us out it does and
like most topics we cover on this
channel today's topic was recommended by
you so if there's a story you'd like to
see or learn more about go to the
yfiles.com tips and huge thanks to our
patrons who keep this channel going I'm
grateful for your kindness and for your
support and if you want to be part of
this amazing Community consider becoming
a member on patreon or grab something
from the Wi-Fi store I'm working on a
mind control invention that will
convince people to buy Heckle fish mugs
and t-shirts well I hope they buy the
stuff because they want to yeah make
them think they want to okay you're
scaring me now that's gonna do it until
next time be safe be kind know that you
are appreciated
[Music]
thank you